قاذفات استراتيجيه امريكيه من طراز بي ون
بي تحلق في سماء كوريا الجنوبيه فالتوترات
في منطقه شرق اسيا بلغت عنان السماء على
خلفيه تجارب صاروخيه كوريه شماليه اثارت
قلق دول الجوار كوريا الجنوبيه والولايات
المتحده قررتها تمديدا مناورات العاصفه
اليقظه المخصصه للرد على اي عدوان من
كوريا الشماليه المناورات التي انتهت
السبت تعهدت يونج بالرد عليها
[موسيقى]
لم تكتف كوريا الشماليه بدالك بل ايضا
وجهه تهديدات علنيه لواشنطن
[موسيقى]
قائمه الاهداف التي ذكرتها كوريا الشماليه
تشمل قواعد جويه وانظمه قياده العمليات
سواء في كوريا الجنوبيه او حتى الولايات
المتحده وهو ما يعد تلميحا باستخدام
الصواريخ البالستيه طويله المدى التي
تملكها بيومنياك والتي يعتقد انها قادره
على حمل رؤوس النوويه